before we get started first of all thank
you so much for coming in today you're
always welcome I sincerely uh before we
get started I want to give a huge thank
you to House of Aurora they're the
sponsor and the reason we're in this
really cool Bank and the only reason I
get to be at if so thank you house if
Aurora really appreciate it now like I
thank you a house of Aurora for feeding
us oh that's true so I want to start
with that but uh so first of all this
was your second time working with Steve
if I'm not mistaken so talk a little bit
about the first time you met him and why
you want it because I'm assuming
everyone asked to work with you what was
it about Steve the first time for 12
years a slave that said I really need to
work with him well actually it was that
I had seen hunger when it first came out
and I thought wow great a new voice a
new director with a new voice with a
real vision and I mean to cut the story
way shots so we had this conversation at
one point or the other when she will
work together you know you know how
those conversations sure and they are
just sort of nebulous and and then I I
got a phone call from Steve one day
going what are you doing in nine o'clock
tomorrow morning I'm going nine o'clock
is not really my time he goes well I'm
screening this film I want you to come
and see and so without any warning
without anything I saw 12 years of slave
at 9 o'clock in the morning and that was
quite an intense experience if you can
imagine and it was it was initially just
down the road from my studio so he just
went back over to the studio and just
started I just started playing and we
you know I mean I don't know you know I
I came fresh off having my heart torn
out by the movie you know straight to a
keyboard and and started working and and
and Steve sort of made my studio his
home you know it's Africa you know it
was
even after we finished the movie like a
week after we finished the movie I'm
wandering down the hallway in there
Steve McQueen
don't forget anything let's just Steve
sort of you know because he liked being
around all the musicians and you know we
are you know we're good hang well you
also have a beautiful studio so it could
just be that he's inspired you have a
very nice setup yeah and you know and
this one we did in London and again it
was it was I don't know I just I think
partly what makes him an extraordinary
director is you know everybody will talk
to you about that he comes from the
visual arts and he has this amazing
background as an artist etc but once you
get to know him you you realize that
there's a there's an enormous heart in
this man you know that there are many
fabulous intellects out there making
movies but ultimately when you dig a
little into Steve and when you really
big because there's a composer you have
to you have to really truly trust the
person you're working with and you get
to know them you know in a very
particular way you find out just how
much heart they're such such a vast
enormous heart that he brings to
everything I thought Widow's was
fantastic
he is so so good with such amazing
performances how early on did Steve call
did he text you and say I want you you
know how early on did you know you're
gonna be involved and what was your
reaction the first time you saw the well
he knew something that most people don't
know that you know it comes from our
television series I've been a Widow's by
Linda LaPlante and when I was working
for Stanley myiasis probably in my
second week or so as his tea boy I was
the tea boy on widows on the original
televisions and so so it was you know I
was the first time I was you know even
allowed near anything that was going on
and at the same time I realized that the
the television series itself or the
story of these women of these characters
was incredibly important this is in the
80s right and so when Steve said
talking about different projects that he
was thinking of doing you know and he
mentioned videos you know I was going at
first of all I told him the story but
secondly I realized why it needed to be
done first because when the original
television series was done we all
thought you know we are showing the you
know the brutality that women live a
woman's life takes place in in in the
world and you know we are going to do
this television series and it's going to
show something and the world is going to
get better and it hasn't gotten better
you know if anything I think it could
become more difficult more you know more
I don't know just just just more callous
in a way so I thought yes it's
absolutely important that we go and do
the film and and and I knew Steve was
the right person to do it so we you the
one instrumental in getting him no no no
not not at all not at all I think it was
very but no because he being
considerably younger than me I I mean he
saw it when he was 13 and it really
affected him and I think you know at the
end of the day I mean I come you know my
mother was a very strong woman and she
had to be very strong woman because the
world was against her in so many
different ways I mean you you can talk
you know you can start off by you're a
refugee from Nazi Germany you know
surviving that you know surviving my
father's death and then you know being
an only woman in a crazy male-dominated
world trying to look after her child and
and so I I thought you know at first
hand saw the struggle of one particular
woman you know who I of course
completely and utterly loved and and I
know so it seemed
it just felt appropriate to go and do
this film sure press what a cast yeah
they were they were okay yeah um when
what was it in terms of because you've
told me before that sometimes you'll pre
write something without seeing something
I could be wrong about this maybe I'm
mistaken oh no you're absolutely right
you're obviously right that's usually
what happens but but here's the thing
the difference working with Sean
bobberts a Steve McQueen and Joe Walker
his editors they have such a musical way
of this it's the only way I can describe
it as they make movies that look like
music you know there's there's a floater
that is so musical so I always feel all
I'm doing is I'm orchestrating and the
music they've already written in a
visual medium and so and I mean
especially Joe who Joe nice Albert first
work together in 1988 so you know we go
back as well and he is actually a
musician I mean he actually went to
music school I am just the Pretender so
you've pretended into an OK spot yeah I
know but one day this summer somebody's
gonna find out but the point of it is
his edits are so incredibly musical and
and there's not a lot of music in
Windows but it it feel about it feels
like that if there's an appropriate
amount of music you know we're us
because the way Joe cuts in the way
sound he uses sound to link out to let
you journey to the next scene etc as
it's all music what was the toughest
thing for you each project I'm sure the
first thing must be the toughest
figuring out maybe the the way in you
know or maybe I'm wrong about well for
me the toughest thing was you know the
the heist part is easy but you know
creating an interesting sense of tension
and propulsion tough is how to show a
woman a strong woman grieving and be
vulnerable and be on her own
without getting sentimental you know to
not rob her for strength and at the same
time to show you know profound
loneliness because unfortunately one of
the things music does automatically it
steals loneliness you know it you know
and so you know it gives the character
companion and so I had to go go against
that in a way I said to you off camera I
will say it on camera your concert that
I saw in Los Angeles was I don't want to
curse on camera I'll use effin amazing
but I think you means [ __ ] amazing
right that's absolutely what I meant I'm
trying to be good but what was it like
because the everyone I spoke to that has
seen this tour I mean everyone loved it
what was it like for you going around
the world and playing these such
magnificent pieces of music with that
band and seeing everyone around the
world reacting in the way they did well
you know the whole thing was I didn't
want to do it because I've stage fright
and all that some stuff and then some of
my musician friends who are wiser than
me actually said that comes a point
where you actually owe it to your
audience to stop hiding behind a screen
and you have to start doing things in
real time and it doesn't matter how
scared you are you you gotta go out
there and you're gonna do it and the
fear never left I don't know that's just
how I'm built you know and it's just
like okay get used to it but go out
there and do it and it it it became this
really extraordinary experience because
it was like we had known each other
forever the audience and myself like we
were penpals but we had never met and we
had never looked each other in the eye
so I treated every night as if it you
know I don't know if it came across in
LA like that but I was basic going it's
just a big dinner party you know just
got my friends are over for big dinner
party and whatever I have no idea what I
said in LA I have no idea what I said in
Toronto whatever comes out of my mouth
will come out of my mouth for better for
worse you know
I only got one city wrong
hello Oslo and Stockholm yeah so you
know yes it's amazing and and and and
the other side of it is of course I was
surrounded by musicians that I have
always loved and after the experience I
you know I love them even more you know
because it's one thing you know coming
in out of the studio but it's another
thing to go around the world and
sometimes under not let's let's say
ideal circumstances like whoever thought
of you know the the routing of Perth to
Helsinki that's that's that that's
that's not your comfy flight me that's
that's not a good one and the jet lag
and the grumpiness and you know and all
that sort of stuff
so and it was an adventure and and but
and I'll do it again because speaker OH
okay Tara I mean you know like Coachella
at first it was like what he want us to
do could tell and then I thought
nobody's ever dragged an orchestra and
the choir out into the desert I think it
has to be done don't you think without a
doubt right so so it was they were
storing stuff like that doing things
which other people hadn't done that that
made it really interesting I have to ask
you so you had retired from the
superhero genre oh right so I need to
ask you what pictures do Simon Kinberg
have that got you to say yes to Dark
Phoenix well it wasn't even that I just
I I had lost my voice somehow do you
mean it's like I died I didn't I didn't
have any new ideas and there's nothing I
don't ever want to phone it in I don't
want to ever not have an idea and I just
sort of made some sort of stupid blanket
statement never you know and Ron Howard
who I really consider as a man of great
wisdom and a great friend quietly said
to me you know house you should never
say no you should always
go I'm waiting for a great story because
the genre doesn't matter you want a
great story and so Simon turned up in
actually in Montreal with the whole with
the whole cast and crew and everybody
for one of the shows and we we just had
a chat and I did about what he wanted to
do and I did I did have an idea of
something that I always wanted to try
you know and it just so happens that it
seems to fit into that sort of a movie
sure I'm not telling you about a taste I
would never I don't know if it's
actually go to work completely one of my
final things for you you're also doing
the Wonder Woman sequel yes and I I love
the first one so great in it beloved
around the world was it a tough thing to
say yes to or were you like it was an
odd thing to say yes to because my
friend Rupert I I had worked really hard
at getting Rupert the job on the first
one but remember that the motif the
Wonder Woman theater is hers is mine
actually you know I wrote that damn
thing I can hear it in my head right now
and we had done it life you know it
became and it became more more
interesting and and I just I just
thought I just thought it was important
to sort of finish it sure you know um
and Patty felt me and she had a share
really interesting ideas well she was we
again that the story she is going to
tell or she is at probably right now on
a set telling you know it it's a story I
want to be part of completely I have a
million other questions for you but
we're gonna do it at another point I
really want to say sincerely thank you
for coming in the studio you're so
welcome and I again I'm you know how
much of a fan I am thank you and thank
you house for aura thank you so much
[Music]